could be the biggest black friday yet
with shoppers expected to spend almost 9
billion pounds in store and online but
some retailers are opting out of the
sales altogether this year saying
discount deals encourage people to buy
things they don't need so is it time
shoppers start to think about the
environmental impact of their bargain
deals judy let's start with you what's
wrong with black friday
i don't think judy can hear us james
i'll put that question to you then
what's the matter with black friday and
getting a good deal
it's a really difficult one for
environmentalists this because no one
wants to be seen to be um you know being
downbeat about things that people enjoy
you know you don't want to be dictating
to people you don't want to be seen to
be preaching and being dull and and sort
of a bit of a party people on this stuff
and and that makes it really challenging
but the the problem is that the level of
consumerism that we see particularly
around black friday particularly when
people are buying things that they don't
really need that serve no real function
they're just there as a real short-term
dopamine hit and that are designed to be
used like once or twice in the case of
some sort of fast fashion items um or
deliberately disposable sort of gifts
that does have an environmental impact
and it's an environmental impact that
you can see very little upside for so um
it's one of the hardest parts of the net
zero transition it's the area that we're
probably least con least confident
around how we can tackle
uh the consumerist culture that's so
embedded into the way the modern economy
works but it is something where new
business models and new approaches are
going to have to be developed if we're
to deliver sort of the deep cuts and
emissions that are needed
and what might those solutions look like
then judy
well some of those solutions really are
supply chains and so on and using
different kinds of energy in order to
produce a product but i think awareness
is the greatest thing many people are
still not aware so they actually don't
choose choosing and campaigning actually
is a huge pressure on business to create
changes the other thing of course is
sheer quantity we shouldn't buy what we
should not need that is something very
simple so without being able to see the
problem on or or anything like that just
by buying exactly what is necessary that
we need will make an enormous difference
in itself yeah i mean there's a stark
figure isn't there that up to 80 percent
of black friday purchases are thrown
away after a very short time but there
are some brands judy aren't there that
are going against black friday
yes a lot of brands are actually saying
that we shouldn't be encouraging
unnecessary sales and we shouldn't be
encouraging people to buy things that
damage the planet and we need to be
aware of the vast ranges of damage not
just in terms of emissions but all sorts
of things like plastics and plastic is
actually getting into the food chain wwf
tells us that each one of us every week
is now eating plastic the size of our
credit card i mean that's quite
frightening we don't know the
implications yet but it shows us that if
we damage nature we in the end damage
our own lives and that's a great
incentive incentive to try and do
something about it
you